[Music]
albert breer joins us on the program of
course senior nfl reporter for the
monday morning quarterback
uh how big a topic uh was mike tomlin at
the owners meeting
i mean it was interesting hearing it you
guys really kicked the hornet's nest
there i guess um
i you know like it's interesting about
it though to me dan and i and i think
that there's a there's random reason
behind this um
i i don't think people realize mike
tomlin now has been in pittsburgh for as
long as bill cower was
and it seems like that's flown by but
it's true he's at 15 years that's a long
tower was there and so you know i think
that there's just a natural thing where
people are going to start asking the
question
is there going to be a next phase of his
career which i'm sure is how the thought
came up with the usc people and i can
tell you i can tell you that like when i
was asking around a couple weeks ago
about the raiders job um after john
gruden resigned there were like would
the raiders
load up and make a huge run at mike
tomlin to restore their credibility
and it actually makes some sense right
like because you think how long these
guys generally stay in these jobs and i
mean 15 years is a long time so
i understand like why tomlin had to do
what he did why he had to say what he
said uh but like i think you know it's
just at a natural point now where he's
been there for 15 years the quarterback
is probably going to be gone after next
year there are big questions going
forward if you're another team or like
one of these big time college programs
and you and i both know there are a
handful of them that are as good as any
nfl job you know no matter how nfl
coaches want to talk about there are a
number of those that have as many pluses
as nfl jobs do
um there's i mean you'd be doing
yourself a disservice not to ask those
questions when you're talking about your
job doesn't mean it's going to progress
anywhere but if you're not thinking of
ideas like that if you're one of those
programs or one of those nfl teams that
have openings then you're not doing your
job you should be asking those questions
again doesn't mean he has any interest
doesn't mean it goes anywhere but that's
the way a program like usc should be
thinking
yeah and you know when he says you know
there's not a blank check big enough by
a booster well there probably is he
makes 8 million dollars with the
steelers and if somebody really wanted
him then they could you know give him 12
15 million dollars a year if they wanted
to but look
i would never leave the steelers
uh if but i don't know mike tomlin so i
don't know what what drives him but he
shouldn't be offended and he shouldn't
bring sean payton and andy reid into the
equation because carson palmer didn't
mention those
coaches there
right right i mean it's like i said like
i think it was sort of taken as
like it was it's like it was like a game
of telephone right like it's like it
like starts as one thing and then by the
time it gets to the other party it's
something else entirely yeah and i mean
it almost sounded like by the time it
got got to tomlin it went from usc would
have discussed this as like kind of a
concept or an idea to
mike tomlin could actually do this you
know what i mean like and it kind of
like felt like that's how he received
the message which i mean i think is i
mean that that's the explanation to why
he would take offense to it um i can't
imagine his name being on a list and
like hey let's just take a swing at this
and see what happens i i don't know why
that would be all that sensitive at all
yeah you know james franklin's name for
usc and lsu now that to me is legitimate
mike tomlin
i don't think he has any interest in
doing that all right uh i kind of gave
the framework for what i'm told on
desean watson that
we knew that they could come up with the
framework for the trade itself it's the
legal framework
what do you think the chances are that
watson is traded by next tuesday
well so miami's been in contact with him
carolina actually talked to him this
week for the first time in a couple
months
and i
like i think caroline is sort of still
monitoring it
denver and philly have been monitoring
it they're less involved right now so
yeah i think for everybody it's the same
thing it's like what's going to happen
with this leaf situation and you know i
it's interesting because like the way
you laid it out right like
it's true like you know no reason to
doubt john mcclane but if you know the
owner in miami who i've been told has
some trepidation over the idea of this
if the owner of miami is
saying we need this thing settled and we
need clarity on what's going to happen
legally and with the league
over the next six days i mean dan how
much leverage would that give i mean
like like watson would not be able to do
it like any like and i don't want to
like i don't want to diminish the
accusations or anything but how much
leverage would that give the accusers
you know what i mean like so
i don't know i mean like i just i don't
see a scenario where everything gets
settled in the next six days you know
what i mean like it's just
it just seems unrealistic to me and i
like
it's just
watson's come this far
and not wanted to settle those cases
like would the would be it being but
being on the precipice of a trade push
him to do a deal that he's you know i
mean basically refused to do over the
course of the last six months it seems
unrealistic yeah you bring up a great
point i didn't think of that if i'm one
of the accusers and then he's traded uh
you know are you gonna
now it feels like we have more leverage
on you for you to settle and on our
terms as opposed to yours but
you know if i'm stephen ross will will
the commissioner tell him what the
punishment's going to be and if i'm
stephen ross can i ask deshaun watson to
settle these cases and then i'll make
the trade for you
and i mean yeah you can i i think the
the hard thing again is like the league
has been
despite what roger said yesterday the
league has been very vague with the
teams about what would happen if he was
traded and um you know what would happen
if they put them back on the field and
how a suspension would work and i think
the league's been intentionally big on
that dan i think the reason why i've
been intentionally
is because i think they've got the
situation right now where they want it
where they don't have to act because
he's not on the field when the texans
are essentially doing the league is
solid because again the league doesn't
have to act but he's not in the public
eye and so this doesn't get discussed on
the sunday morning shows this isn't a
weekly topic there are protesters
outside of a stadium if he gets traded
it goes back on the field the dynamic
changes all together and so you know i
think that piece of it i that piece of
it is a i know and for some teams that
were involved has like cooled some
interest there
and um and yeah i mean like i just it's
just really really hard for me to see
where there's going to be a whole lot
more clarity legally or from the league
in the next six days
the
washington football team that
investigation the commissioner basically
saying there's nothing to see here let's
move on
um
you know how does this go to the next
step where
they actually have some of this
investigation revealed publicly
i mean i i like the history tells us
it's not going to be real i mean like i
i hate you know i i like my my
experience here has sort of taught me to
be a skeptic and i mean like and you can
look at it look at the history right
like so tom brady deflated football's
250 page report you can google it it's
right there on the internet
um you know which incognito bullying and
a lot i mean like basically a middle
middle school situation right
and i mean
like 150 page report federal
investigators conducting these reports
you can find them on the internet ray
rice the domestic violence um situation
that was obviously way more serious than
incognito or brady but that 100 page
report
you know and like now try to find
anything on gary richardson try to find
anything coming from the league on jerry
jones or robert crap like it just
doesn't happen you know and so
i think this is the way the league's
always conducted business when it comes
to owners and you know i think anything
they've said about owners being held to
a higher standard than players you know
it rings hollow when you actually look
at the facts and my guess is
they're gonna just keep kicking the can
down the road and hoping that people
lose interest in our story
um
it's just i mean like like i said like i
think
if you're another owner like i would
think that you would look at this and
say
you need to at least like have some
transparency on this and this is
reflecting poorly on all of us i think
the issue is
that no owner wants the precedence out
of you know the league being able to
take anyone's team away yeah
their owners have skeletons in their
closet
and so you know i i think this is
probably going to remain where it is
right now
and nothing the commissioner said
yesterday would change my mind on that i
know you have a busy day thanks for
joining us on short notice albert we
appreciate it
you got dan anytime that's albert breer
monday morning quarterback